pour les titres commence donc avec cette
nouvelle tant attendue la fin du port du
masque comment cette décision at elle
été prise malgré la hausse des
contaminations explications avec jérôme
rabier
c'est pour l'instant un rebond pas
encore une sixième vague mais l'épidémie
de covin repart à la hausse en france
les chiffres quotidiens publiés par
santé publique france sont formels sur
les sept derniers jours il ya eu en
moyenne plus de 65000 cas quotidiens
soit une hausse de près de 25% en une
semaine et cela va probablement durer un
peu pour l'épidémiologiste arnaud
fontanet qui s'appuie sur les
projections de l'institut pasteur grâce
au niveau d'immunité collectif qu'on a
acquis par la vaccination par les
infections passer ce pic devrait aller
jusqu'à 100 milles par jour peut-être
150 milles on est quand même loin des
350 mille cas par jour de la mi janvier
qui était le pic de la vague au micron
et après les choses devraient s'arranger
et on peut espérer qu'avec le printemps
aussi on arrive dans une période où la
circulation du virus tramway en
attendant une éventuelle accalmie les
indicateurs virent au rouge
22,4 pour cent des tests réalisés se
révèle positif un chiffre qui repart à
la hausse pour la première fois depuis
le pic de janvier logiquement le taux
d'incidence suit le même rythme avec 6
129 cas positifs pour cent mille
habitants mais pour le président du
conseil scientifique
on ne peut pas parler de sixième vague
on est bien dans la cinquième vague qui
se poursuit qui est lié à au micron il y
à une augmentation c'est clair mais
celle ci nous paraît maîtrisa au moment
où les restrictions comme le masque
obligatoire sont levés dans de nombreux
secteurs le gouvernement appelle à
rester vigilant en particulier pour les
plus fragiles l'ouverture de la campagne
de 4e dos pour les plus de 80 ans et les
personnes immunodéprimées c'est
d'ailleurs ouverte aujourd'hui la faim
dépasse vaccinale on en débat tout de
suite dans ce sens public avec christine
rouzioux bonsoir en soirée avenue vous
êtes professeur émérite de virologie à
l'université paris descartes membre des
académies de médecine et de pharmacie
claude malhuret bonsoir sénateur de
l'allier présidents des groupes les
indépendants république et territoires
où soutenait emmanuel macron jean daniel
lévy bonsoir directeur délégué harris
interactive france avec nos également en
duplex en visioconférence corinne féret
qui est sénatrice socialiste du calvados
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir mathieu sous-entendant
christine rouzioux est ce que vous vous
parlez de sixième vague on entendait le
professeur delfraissy à l'instant dans
notre oui je pense que ça va monter
c'est évident que ça va monter il ya
plusieurs circonstances qui vont faire
que ça va monter il ya le retour à
l'école pour la zone c il ya bahia cette
libération des vasques des masques je
dis bien libération c'est plus une
obligation c'est une liberté de le
garder voilà comment je dis les choses
parce que je pense que le virus est là
il circule beaucoup c'est un nouveau
variant cba deux c1 un cousin de au
micron disons qu'il se branche sur le
même arbre que micron et et il diffère
un peu il est encore plus contagieux
committee vient encore beaucoup plus
contagieux à 30% plus contagieux comique
rond il et les pathogènes relativement
pathogènes dans la mesure où ce qu'on
voit par exemple à hong kong avec une
mortalité importante on fera la chine
qui confine des zones de 7 millions de
de personnes fâchées n'aurions il a à
shenzhen
et on voit que vraiment c'est un virus
tueur quoi y'a pas de soucis il faut pas
il faut s'en méfier donc cette
obligation de masques qui tombent pour
moi c'est simplement une liberté de le
garder donc vous pensez que c'est un peu
prématuré si jolie quand
ça a été annoncé à un moment où cette
sixième vague qui pour moi est en train
de démarrer n'était pas encore n'était
pas encore là le bea de été au danemark
à ce moment là mais en france en février
on était encore avec le au micro ondes
un type ainsi si vous voulez là on est
avec le mot micron type 2 ba2 dominant
et avec évidemment des disparités
régionales comme d'habitude mais mais un
risque un risque de réinfection
y compris les gens qui ont eu au micro à
un risque évidemment pour les personnes
fragiles donc moi vraiment je je je
soutiens le fait qu' il faut continuer à
se protéger il faut continuer à se
protéger les autres je pense qu'on passe
avec cette cette obligation qui tombe on
passa à cette vie à la japonaise c'est à
dire que maintenant les gens convives
ont porté le masque tout le temps
beaucoup quand ils auront un rhume quand
ils auront une crypte je pense qu'on va
passer à ce mode de vie et que les gens
ont pris l'habitude de la voir on y
reviendra parce que effectivement c'est
intéressant claude malhuret à
entendre le professeur uzi on se disent
peut-être une décision quand même plus
politique que sanitaire même si on
comprend la difficulté de prendre une
telle décision avec un virus qui mute
c'est qu'ils évoluent rapidement je
crois que le politique est là pour
prendre des décisions à une kangoo 10
est plus politique que sanitaire
c'est le rôle du monde assume c'est le
rôle du politique j'observe d'ailleurs
en écoutant
fontanes et en écoutant delfraissy en
vous écoutant que les scientifiques et
je m'en félicite que les scientifiques
sont beaucoup plus prudents qu'ils ne
l'étaient
j'ai vu au début il ya longtemps au
début de cette crise les scientifiques
s'affronter dire des choses extrêmement
tôt bonal les imparables aujourd'hui
tout le monde pas seulement les
scientifiques et remet tout le monde est
plus prudent
souligne les avantages soulignent les
inconvénients soulignent les risques
mais avec beaucoup moins de certitudes
avant et par conséquent c'est le moment
le lieu ou le politique doit trancher il
le fait aujourd'hui avec certes un
certain nombre d'incertitudes mais je ne
pense pas quand vous dites ce que c'est
une décision politique vous
sous-entendez un état dans l'état le
premier temps de la nation le politique
joue son rôle il leur joue dans les pays
voisins les levées de restriction sont
un petit peu partout au même moment à 15
jours près et par conséquent je pense
que
voilà tout en écoutant les lélés les
avertissements les bêtes précaution
demandé par les scientifiques il faut
bien ça a été le cas à plusieurs
reprises au cours des épidémies faut
bien un jour prendre des décisions et je
pense si on la voit comme vous le dites
et un instant comme une liberté et comme
le fait pour le garder
j'allais lire dans le sens une liberté
d'exprimer sa responsabilité ça prouve
son habilité après tout je trouve c'est
une mesure tout à fait normale et je ne
je n'y vois pas en tout cas derrière
pensées électorales et vous corinne
féret comment vous recevez cette cette
journée on est à la fois heureux de voir
des visages sans masque et c'est vrai
que le discours d d
les médecins des professeurs d
président du conseil scientifique on se
dit est ce que c'est vraiment le bon
moment et vous
est à la fois effectivement
tous nos concitoyens tous nous tous nous
attendions ce moment où on pourrait
enfin retrouver le sourire face à nous
et avoir cette liberté on réduit avec
des guillemets que les spécialistes et
bonnaire me vient de faire reste très
prudent ignorant qu'ils seront tout à
fait dans l'ordre de fait l'épidémie
repart au front on voit bien et quatre
nominations
augmenté donc il faut rester extrêmement
prudent il faut une semble-t-il
maintenir tous ses gestes barrière n'a
appris à vivre avec on a appris à vivre
avec le match qu'on a appris à se laver
les mains x fois dans la journée je
pense qu'il faut préserver tout ça
notamment pour les personnes les plus
fragiles pour les personnes âgées ils se
sont montrés fragiles mais aussi leur
entourage des diamants donc c'est une
autre une autre phase d'épidémie dans
notre comportement de notre façon de
vivre je veux dire enfin d'une certaine
façon on a vu tomber le masque mais
qu'il faut rester prudent et on peut
être faux répondront que vous posiez la
question pas même si évidemment les
politiques sont là pour prendre des
décisions
lorsqu'il ya des moments où on va dire
mais en particulier dans des situations
aussi grave et aussi complexe que celle
que nous vivons nous subissons de
maintenant pour autant ce 14 mars est
peut-être très d'une échéance
présidentielle mais je ne veux
absolument pas y voir un lien
politiciens environ ou d'intérêt
politique au sens
électoraliste corps je pense que la flf
c'est l'intérêt de notre nation est la
grèce ne rien entendre
je vais
vous interrompre la liaison n'est pas
très très bonne on va essayer
d'améliorer ça j'en suis convaincu gens
de lévis et c'est assez intéressant
aussi effectivement s est ce que pour
autant l'opinion
crédit très où est ce que je vais dire
le prêt dans la république d'une telle
décision si on était dans un calcul bon
et ma question est un peu alambiqué mais
je suis sûr vous l'aï comprise en tout
cas tel que je l'accomplis sk calcul ou
pas la part des responsables politiques
au jeu des français la réponse est oui
voilà donc ce tdr ils disent on a une
émission qui va se dérouler le 10 avril
prochain il ya un stand de choses qui
apparaissent comme étant profondément
pénible pour les citoyens il ya un
aspect concernant le pouvoir d'achat et
notamment en fait le prix de l'essence
et puis il ya également le port du
masque et toutes les contraintes
sanitaires qu'on peut avoir à l'heure
actuelle je mélange un peu mais dans
l'esprit des français c'est souvent un
peu comme ça on dit bah tiens on se
rapproche de l'élection et ses petites
épines qu'on a aujourd'hui dans le pied
ben quand même le gouvernement va nous
adresser des messages avec deux
registres je pense qu'ils sont
importants d'avoir l'esprit le premier
aspect c'est qu'il ya quand même une
confiance qui est assez grande en
matière de santé publique et exprimé
aujourd'hui à l'égard du gouvernement et
du président de la répliquer mais qu'à
voir le fait que au début la pandémie on
parlait aux yeux des français matin midi
et soir du nombre de morts est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un non sujet et
donc on va plutôt parler des
contaminations mais on parle même pas
d'engorgement des hôpitaux on parle même
pas aujourd'hui en fait de plans ben
quoi donc globalement c'est un une
situation qui apparaît comme étant
relativement bien géré et puis deuxième
aspect c'est un peu j'y pense et puis
j'oublie voilà ces jeux je pense à ces
situations là et puis en même temps j'ai
comme envie d'avoir un peu cet espoir de
revenir à une situation intérieure en me
disant qu'il ya quand même un risque
peut-être de porter de ne pas porter le
masque de vivre un peu plus comme avant
mais que
nous faisons moins en moins envie ou en
tout cas la pression qui existe en fait
à titre individuel un peu moins
importante donc on a pas forcément de
critiques manifeste à l'égard du
gouvernement en disant c'est uniquement
une mesure électoraliste aujourd'hui
sans considération ou sans mettre en
danger fondamentalement notre pays on va
pas folle et les électeurs ont pas
forcément voté macron dans trois
semaines parce que l on leur a proposé
de retirer le masque le 14 mars un nom
et 2 les électeurs qui étaient les plus
critiques à l'égard de la gestion
sanitaire de cette dernière période ne
se retrouver ni dans l'électorat
aujourd'hui d'emmanuel mâcon ni même
dans l'électorat potentiel des manuels
macron donc le haut de leur gain
manifeste en matière de comportement
électoral n'est absolument pas à trouver
auprès de ceux qui étaient les plus
critiques concernant la gestion des
crises sanitaires effectivement et
mathieu on peut on peut le dire il avait
un tout petit peu évoquée mais c'est
intéressant de creuser ce thème le
copain c'est le grand absent pour
l'instant de cette campagne oui est ce
que vous avez entendu des candidats
présidentiels s'émouvoir de l'allègement
des restrictions sanitaires est ce que
vous avez entendu remettre en cause les
choix du gouvernement indien qu'il
faudrait plutôt faire comme si dire
qu'il faudrait plutôt faire comme sa
gamme et non un relatif consensus
politique autour désormais la gestion de
la crise qu vide il paraît loin le temps
où l'opposition ne ménagerait pas ses
critiques dénonçant l'impréparation les
mensonges les manques de masquer les
manques de test les manque de vaccins
l'époque où certains criaient
souvenez-vous au scandale d'état
l'époque où d'autres criaient à
l'apartheid après deux ans de ce
pandémie la france semble selon
l'expression consacrée avoir appris à
vivre avec le virus et la classe
politique avec alors pour l'exécutif
c'est un vrai soulagement et un encore
moi je me souviens des stratèges de
l'élysée comme on dit empêtré dans une
campagne vaccinale qui était alors à la
peine il redoutait deux scénarios le
premier c'était que la pandémie
s'installe et que les français abouo
finissent par sanctionner l'exécutif et
le second c'était que la pandémie que la
situation s'améliore mais que les
français à bout finissent par
sanctionner l'exécutif aussi au nom de
ce qu'ils appelaient les faits de
churchill en évoquant le premier brennus
pour premier ministre parlant anglais
victorieux au lendemain de la guerre de
la seconde guerre mondiale mais battu
dans les urnes juste après alors comment
ça s'explique finalement cette
mansuétude on va dire d y avait un effet
de comparaison parce que deux ans ont
permis aux français de comprendre que
les ressorts de cette pandémie mondiale
n'avait pas renié personnes et que la
france malgré de réels retard à
l'allumage mais au final ne sentirait
pas forcément plus mal que ses voisins
et ensuite un effet de lassitude on peut
s'en désole jean daniel il faisait
allusion tout à l'heure mais le coc vide
qui tue encore plus de 100 personnes par
jour et en a fait 148 morts au total
quand même ça n'effraie plus ni n'émeut
plus grand monde le contexte national
international pèse aussi une peur chasse
l'autre et puis enfin et surtout la
façon dont l'exécutif a fini par gérer
la crise en 2021 notamment après les
tâtonnements les erreurs initiales les
choix présidentiels de porter l'économie
à bout de bras avec le quoi qu'il en
coûte les choix de ne plus affiné le
confinement de ne plus tarder ont
infligé de confinement qu'en dernier
ressort et c'est un peu ce qu'a fait mme
hamel macron à l'an dernier où surtout
de faire avancer le pays à marche forcée
vers la vaccination par le biais du pass
sanitaire puis du patac signal mais tout
ça a un peu changé le regard des
français et la gestion de la crise qu
vide qui était un boulet bas est devenu
presque un atout pour emmanuel macron
sondage après sondage jean-daniel
démentir et si c'est pas le carré les
français sont de plus en plus nombreuses
pas forcément accrédités ou a donné
quitus à l'exécutif pour sa gestion mais
qu'est ce que vivent tous cas à
considérer que personne au fond aucun de
ses rivaux n'aurait fait vraiment mieux
lionel macron et puis la santé est
devenue un enjeu un terminera
intermittent de cette campagne est
davantage sous l'angle des moyens
alloués à l'hôpital ou de la lutte
contre les déserts médicaux mais pas pas
vraiment sur la politique sanitaire pas
vraiment sur la gestion de la crise qu
vide au fond puisque personne n'a
tellement d'idées de faire autrement à
condition toutefois que la politique et
que l'épidémie pardon ne remettent pas à
flamber d'ici quelques semaines et
notamment l avait dit oui justement
c'était la question que j'allais vous
posez christine rouzioux parce que on
peut se projeter quand il ya une
épidémie en général je voyais les
chiffres que prévoyait
l'institut pasteur plus de cent mille
cas par jour à la fin du mois de mars
donc si on se projette au 10 avril on
peut être dans quelle situation
épidémiologique à ce moment là oui je
pense que les modélisations de simon que
je fais à mon avis sont sont
relativement
exact la mesure où il ya tout pour que
le virus continue à courir il n'y a
aucun problème
c'est vrai que l'immunité global
collective dont on parle et en est pas
si mal il ya eu pas mal de gens infectés
par au micro il a fait beaucoup de rues
mais de grippe sans faire
d'hospitalisation mais parce que
justement il ya un fond immunitaire
correct mais bon voilà il ya quand même
un certain nombre de morts tous les
jours comme vous l'avez dit moi j'arrive
pas à vivre avec cette idée 140 morts
par jour qui passe à la trappe comme ça
systématiquement c'est quand même
insupportable et en même temps on sait
qu'on est à peu près à 10% semblant de
la population qui n'a pas été infectés
qui n'a pas été vaccinés qui est très à
risque de au micro de ça on le sait
c'est clair que on risque d'avoir un
petit rebond à l'hôpital un faux-pas
faut pas se leurrer il ya encore des
choses à faire alors la chose à faire
qui à mon avis pas très très bien
explicités par le gouvernement c'est la
vaccination la quatrième dose je pense
que cette quatrième dose c'est bien de
dire les 80 ans mais pourquoi pas les 79
surtout en ehpad je pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin il faut vraiment inciter
tous les immunodéprimés les gens avec un
système immunitaire
fragiles les personnes âgées même qu'ils
sont pas en ehpad parce que parce que
voilà je travaille pas mal avec les
ehpad du groupe sos je vois bien que
dans quelle situation ils sont pas
vaccinés que les 80 ans et pas les 79
ans alors que le virus circule beaucoup
ya qu un certain nombre d pad avec du
virus mais il n'ya pas d'hospitalisation
n'y a pas de forme grave il n'y a pas
une létalité parce que finalement cette
immunité qu'on a mis avec une troisième
dose en septembre c'était quand même
bien longtemps finalement
elle tient la route elle tient la route
donc cette idée de dire 80 en trois mois
sans aller plus loin l'élargir alors que
les centres vaccinaux sont là et tous
que les quatrièmes doses sont là je
pense que voilà il va falloir l'ouvrir
un tout petit peu plus mais claude
malhuret c'est vrai que c'est l'une des
annonces qui est passé un petit peu
inaperçu peut-être parce que beaucoup
plus de 80 ça concerne je mets plein dit
mais pas grand monde et donc on en a on
a le sentiment et sa aliments peut-être
un sentiment général que ça y est on
peut lâcher le masque c'est derrière
nous alors que vous dites ou les tous
les spécialistes il faut maintenir les
gestes barrière il faut peut-être porter
le masque quand on va voir une personne
de sa famille qu'est une personne
potentiellement à risque ça il ya une
petite musique de liberté qui fait que
l'information sur quatrième dose pour
les plus de 80 est passé un peu à la
trappe quoi oui je pense d'ailleurs que
c'est peu c'est peut-être provisoire
parce que si on voit un rebond
voir une sixième vague très rapidement
le gouvernement on va voir à communiquer
d'abord avoir à prendre des mesures à
voir étendre cette cette disposition est
par conséquent il mais aujourd'hui la
communication je le pousse à prendre ça
c'est votre métier au comedy club par
séquence est une chose à la fois donc on
n'est pas dans cette on n'est pas dans
cette séquence là on est dans la
séquence oui on peut aujourd'hui tout
tout bien pesé
et élargir les choses et et diminuer les
restrictions mais pour en revenir à ce
que vous disiez il ya un instant sur le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas qu'il n'y ait pas
de contestation au bout d'un an au bout
de deux ans d'ailleurs mais aujourd'hui
libre il a deux ans y ont alors que y
compris ce politiquement vous voyez
i'm fair est à peu près sur la même la
même ligne que moi sur ce sujet je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose qu'il faut peut
être rappeler c'est que le ce qui en
dehors de sa gestion de la crise mais ce
qui a aussi beaucoup conforter le
gouvernement et le ministre de la santé
c'est aussi la position comment dire
j'allais dire ridicule est de plus en
plus ridicule au fil des mois de ses
adversaires n'ont pas des adversaires
sérieux mais les adversaires qu'on était
les anti pacs qui se sont quittés ce
début sont décrédibilisés mais qui petit
à petit se sont plus se sont ridiculisés
qui se sont révélées être évidemment les
extrêmes politiques évidemment les
complotistes serra et je dirais que ce
ça a été tellement ridicule tsar est
tellement hors sujet que ça conforter
aussi largement que pas par effet de
miroir si vous voulez vous par effet
contraire
ça contrario sa fortifiée
l'adhésion des français aux discours du
gouvernement qui était un discours de
sérieux et donc aujourd'hui ça entraîne
encore une fois par raisonnement par
l'absurde ça entraîne une adhésion à la
position responsable du gouvernement un
tweet signée olivier verrons aujourd'hui
voilà ce que nous dit le ministre sentez
vous n'êtes aujourd'hui vous n'êtes plus
obligé de porter un masque ni de
présenter votre passé nous l'attendions
tous à l'inflammation mais aujourd'hui
comme hier fragiles ou en présence de
personnes fragiles rester vigilant
maintenez les gestes barrière c'est ce
que effectivement
j'ai entendu aussi dans la bouche de
plusieurs scientifiques aujourd'hui je
propose un style jourdain qui doit pas
être très loin et
de nous rejoindre mon soir steve parce
que il ya quand même une question autour
des objectifs
affichés par olivier v ans il vient de
donner la parole en lisant 100 tweets
tous ces objectifs n'ont pas été
atteints non flash back dans le monde
d'avant d'avant la guerre en ukraine
alliée verront était auditionné au sénat
le 22 février thomas il était devant la
commission denquête mise en place pour
évaluer la nécessité ou non de maintenir
le pass vaccinale au regard de la
situation sanitaire le pass vaccinale
qui entre en vigueur le 24 janvier
olivier ferrand était donc auditionné un
mois après le 22 février au lit les
héros plutôt optimiste sur l'évolution
de l'épidémie écoutez c'est il ya trois
semaines nous avons indiqué que si cette
trajectoire positive se confirmait en
particulier sur le plan des tensions
hospitalières et en terme de circulation
du virus nous pourrions envisager une
levée du pass à la mi mars dans tout ou
partie des lieux où il est mis en place
et le mini de la santé avait fixé des
critères précis pour ce que l'on est en
train de lui c'est à dire la levée des
restrictions sanitaires précisément
notamment la levée du port du masque en
intérieur et la levée du pass vaccinale
quels étaient ces critères fixés par
olivier ferrand eh bien il fallait
passer sous la barre des 1500 patients
qu'aux vide en réanimation écoutez le ce
que nous disent les scientifiques le
conseil scientifique etc c'est qu' il
faudrait qu'on redescende aux alentours
de 1500 patients kobinan real
pour qu'on considère que le
fonctionnement normal les hôpitaux
seraient restaurés ce qui à ce rythme
pourrait intervenir d'ici deux à trois
semaines deuxième indicateur rapidement
c'est la dynamique épidémique est là le
conseil scientifique nous il faut que le
facteur aire de reproduction du virus
soit durablement inférieure à un tir
qu'on soit sur une pente décroissante et
que on a atteint un niveau de taux
d'incidence qu'ils soient assez faibles
entre 300 et 500 aux plus forts au
maximum pour pouvoir considérer qu' on a
vraiment franchi le plus dur 1500
patients commises en réanimation on
n'est pas tout à fait non maintenant il
hier dimanche 13 mars le nom de patients
qu'aux vide en réanimation était de 1855
certains le chiffre baisse et baisse
vraiment depuis la mi-janvier faut
rappeler qu'à la mi janvier on était
autour de 4000 patients qu'aux vide en
réanimation mais aujourd'hui on est donc
au dessus du seuil
d'hospitalisation fixé par olivier
verrons pour la levée de ces
restrictions et pour le moment pas du
tout question de changer la stratégie
sanitaire de l'eau du côté du
gouvernement m merci steve jour d'impôts
pour tous ces détails christine rouzioux
7 vous parlez de sixième vague on est
bien d'accord je voudrais détaillé ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure sur le
nombre de personnes ne savent souvent
renvoyés en réanimation est ce que ce
nouveau variant dont vous nous parliez
qui est plus contagieux est ce que il
risque et moi j'espère que non
évidemment un oiseau de mauvaise augure
mais lloris d'envoyer beaucoup de gens
dans réalisation alors la littérature
nous montre qu' il est un peu différent
de au micron 1 dans la mesure au micro
un restaurant les voies aériennes
supérieures alors que là dans les
modèles animaux notamment le modèle
vision épurée on a un micron 2 qui a
plutôt une affinité pour le poumon alors
on n'a pas encore les résultats de deux
des situations cliniques qui sont
observés à hong kong mais disons que
voilà il ya ces craintes de modification
de pouvoir pathogène qui sont qui sont
pas du tout anodine cela dit le reste de
la population à drjscs et bien
évidemment comme on l'a dit c'est le non
vaccinés qui qu'il a sont un risque de
formes graves plus que pour delta plus
que pour au micro ont encore une fois
regardons hong kong où on est à 30 % de
vaccination entre deux dozois de doses
mais avec des vaccins chinese like donc
pas ou qui sont moins efficaces et
beaucoup moins efficace et des vaccins
tuer c'est pas du tout ce boost énorme
de protéines qu'on achève un kick et
produit par l'organisme avec les vaccins
arn messager qui sont maintenant ça y
est reconnu comme l'efficacité évidente
là maintenant on en a la preuve quand on
voit le nombre de personnes infectées
par au micron qui n'ont pas et l hôpital
qui n'ont pas fait de forme grave je
crois que là les non vaccinés
c'est fini quoi les antilles vague c'est
terminé c'est des milliards de personnes
qui ont été vaccinées et c'est des
millions de personnes qui ont été
protégés donc oui il nous reste 10 % de
la population à risque à qui il faut
dire faites un ancien vous faites
attention à votre environnement
bayal et donc les proches pendant
interrompre mes proches de ces personnes
à risque roche et personnages et qui
sont encore une fois qu'ils vont qui
font leurs courses etc en plus en plus
on a une circulation des virus grippaux
en ce moment je 3-1 h3n1 et h1n1 a h3n2
donc c'est pas voilà c'est le printemps
arrive c'est sûr
ça fait deux ans qu'on tient encore
quelques semaines et c'est fini je vous
propose d'écouter un autre excellent
attendu jean françois delfraissy
président conseil scientifique dans le
nôtre sujet d'ouverture tout à l'heure
mais je vous propose un autre ex thé ce
matin sur rtl il parlait de
l'acceptabilité du masque notamment chez
les plus jeunes en écoute
françois delfraissy
on n'est pas dans blanc et noirs c'est à
dire que je comprends il est impossible
actuellement de demander à une
population jeune en france avec le
niveau de circulation virale que nous
avons de continuer à porter le masque
c'est pas possible ça ne on peut
toujours prendre des mesures obligé
entre guillemets dans une certaine
mesure ça n'aurait pas marché jean
daniel lévy l'acceptabilité par les
jeunes est ce qu on voit effectivement
je sais pas si vous avez ça dans vos
enquêtes d'opinion mais une espèce de
rejet qui commençait à monter parce que
c'est l'impression qu'on a donc il ya
une très très grande lassitude favoris
n'étaient pas encore exactement au
niveau du projet on a dit quand même
beaucoup de choses sur les jeunes on est
en fait une zone quand même parfois un
peu surpris je vais tenter de dire
surpris en bien on savait peut-être au
mois de décembre de cela deux ans en
fait on s'était demandé s'il serait pas
des facteurs de contamination notamment
à l'égard de leurs parents aux grands
parents au moment des fêtes de fin
d'année
ils ont eu souvent à un esprit de
responsabilité quitte à eux mêmes ne pas
aller rejoindre leurs proches en famille
non pas pour eux-mêmes se protéger mais
pour éviter de contaminer les autres et
ce qui avait été présenté comme étant
absolument inévitable c'est à dire un
pic majeur à la rentrée 2021 ne s'est
pas produit notamment parce qu'il ya eu
cette forme d'esprit de responsabilité
de la part de la part des jeunes il ya
peut-être le deuxième aspect c'est que
nous quand on fait des études et quand
on demande aux français vraiment le
respect du geste des gestes-barrières à
tous les niveaux que ce soit ne pas
serrer la main ne pas faire la bise
portait bien le masque et surtout pour
les masques jetables le changer à
intervalles réguliers pour la quand même
plus de 80% des français qui respectent
pas à 100% la totalité des
gestes-barrières donc même quelle que
soit la tranche d'âge autres il ya quand
même aujourd'hui parfois enfin voilà
fade et un respect qui est loin d'être
d'être absolue qui est un peu plus
manifestes de la part des jeunes parce
qu'on sait qu'ils sont en général moins
sensibles aux cocos campagne en matière
de santé ils se sentent moins
vulnérables que les autres ils sont
parfois surtout quand ce sont des hommes
un peu plus en maîtrise eux-mêmes et en
capacité à pouvoir s'en sortir si jamais
ils jouent une forme de difficultés mais
on à une césure générationnel qui ferait
qu'on aurait d'un côté des jeunes qui
basculerait complètement dans un refus
absolu et deux des personnes âgées qui
au contraire respecterait complètement à
ses gestes barrières mais en même temps
quelle incroyable moment de discipline
collective mais bien suffit quand même
de l'état deux ans les gaulois
réfractaires nous
respecter les confinements ils sont fait
vacciner ils auront globalement respecté
les gestes barrière c'est peut-être la
différence des japonais en général le
masque vu comme étant une protection à
titre individuel que les villes le fait
d'éviter de contaminer les autres et
c'est dans le cadre des études en fait
il est cette petite différence d'un
accord quand vous prenez le métro à
tokyo vous voyez bien que celui qui tout
ce qui porte son masque c'est oui c'est
ce que je disais donc ça se passe comme
ça et en
france aux français pas forcément en
fait l'idée d'enfin l'égard des
personnes âgées sauf à l'égard des
personnes fragiles on a vu beaucoup de
jeunes je trouve que l'acceptabilité
aussi des jeunes concernant la
vaccination a été évidente alors qu'on a
beaucoup plu beaucoup plus de
difficultés pour la vaccination des
enfants et donc je suis d'accord avec
vous on n'a pas eu une grosse vague
épidémique au retour des vacances mais
par contre le nombre d'enfants affectés
a été quand même on a déjà largement
dépassé le million c'est voir beaucoup
plus donc et là au micro encore à
beaucoup sévi ces derniers temps chez
les enfants je voudrais d'abord je pense
que techniquement c'est meilleur à
corinne féret qui est avec nous en
duplex peut-être pour parler du se passe
vaccinale corinne féret
quel bilan vous en fait on
est ce que vous dites tout ça pour ça il
y aura servi à quoi selon vous se passe
vaccinale alors non je ne dis pas tout
important mais comme vous l'avez rappelé
le tenait à
élaborer un rapport qu'il a remis il ya
à peine quinze jours le 3 février ont
souhaité connaître un peu justement le
bien fondé de ce padd maximale et
pouvoir quantifier on pourrait dire son
application ou ses conséquences sur
l'épidémie il n'a pas peut-être atteint
véritablement l'enfant ont le niveau de
nos pensions pour autant je pense qu'il
a fait pendre conscience à chacun et
chacune d'entre nous que la vaccination
était une excellente protection madame
l'a rappelé je pense que là toute
l'année chez eux qu' il trouvait à
redire sur l'intérêt le bien fondé de la
vaccination non plus cette hausse est
objet ou de cette objection pardon je
veux charles onians le moment sur il me
semble nécessaire de relancer la
campagne de vaccination que cela parce
qu'on tourne le mac aujourd'hui
l'épidémie et vous venez de dire est
bien évidemment l'épidémie a disparu non
il faut inciter encore et toujours les
français à se faire vacciner une dose de
doses à troisième donne les centres de
vaccination pour beaucoup d'entre eux
ont été fermés mais on voit bien que
jack six nations que ce père qui est
formé de cinq ans aucune difficulté donc
il faut vraiment insister là dessus
parce que être cinquième mois s'ils
gagnent sable et le clapier la pente qui
il reste encore beaucoup de franches et
quel que soit leur âge y compris dans
les personnes les plus âgées il y en a
encore beaucoup qui ne sont pas vaccinés
mais aussi chez les plus jeunes aux
filles peuvent transmettre justement le
virus est bien et qui peuvent donc être
aussi contaminé bien sûr quand je dis
cela cette campagne de vaccination elle
doit perdurer et le gouvernement devrait
relancer ou l'option publique devrait
être de relancer une campagne de
vaccination en fonction de nos
concitoyens claude malhuret
on parlait de d'acceptabilité de
libertés publiques c'est vrai qu'on a
renoncé
certain nombre de libertés pratiquement
du jour au lendemain sans
[Musique]
sans mobilisation alors qu'on aurait pu
imaginer voir mais beaucoup de gens dans
la rue est ce que vous pensez que ça
restera sa
queue
pour une longue durée dans dans les
habitudes emparé de la société japonaise
dans l'état d'esprit les habitudes des
français jeu
je pense qu'il n'est pas souhaitable que
ça dure je veux dire c'est ça a duré 2
est d'ailleurs ce qu'explique le
gouvernement depuis le début c'est ce
qu'il a expliqué dans l'es12
audition qu'il ya eu au sénat nm les
douze décisions législatives qui a eu au
sénat et à l'assemblée c'est que c'est
une situation d'urgence et d'une
situation exceptionnelle c'est une
situation d'ailleurs dont on regrette
qu'elles durent puisqu'elle a commencé
au moment des attentats terroristes et
oui et puis qu'aujourd'hui c'est
sellerie donc il ya 1 1000e et la maison
d'habitude qui s'installe quand voilà
une leur habitude les installe mais moi
je compte sur le sur le
gouvernement et sur l' assemblée sénat
bien entendu pour des que la crise
sanitaire sera fini nous sommes nous
enlevions toutes les mesures d'urgence
et qu'on sait c'est d'ailleurs ce que le
conseil d'état lorsqu'il a eu à étudier
les différentes lois c'est ce sur quoi
il a insisté le conseil constitutionnel
aussi tant qu'il s'agit d' urgence nous
acceptons un certain nombre de choses et
comme vous le dites les français l'ont
très bien accepté et je crois que
c'était une preuve de maturité de
responsabilité mais en même temps je
pense effectivement elle ce point de vue
là on n'est pas tellement japonais
je pense qu'il souhaite que le jour où
c'est fini on en efface tout ça et qu'on
revienne à une situation qui est la
situation démocratique normal
il ya peut-être des choses qui vont
rester peut-être le fait de se laver
plus fréquemment les mains oui le fait
de pas forcément faire la mise lorsqu'on
est un peu enrhumé même pas très bien où
le fait de ne pas serrer la main en tout
cas ces trois types de deux gestes qui
sont pas forcément enfin on va dire très
privative de liberté mais qui commence
aujourd'hui entré dans les moeurs et
même voilà parfois quand on est amené
sur des sujets annexes à travail auprès
des français on voit bien que quand ils
voient des images il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça il ya deux mois quatre
ans en fait avec des personnes qui
entrent sans masque quelque part et qui
vont s'embrasser tu sais il ya un petit
mouvement qui est d'un mouvement
interrogatif l'interrogation milan est
ce que tout ceci est bien responsable
donc je pense pas qu'on va ne plus avoir
du tout de contact physique mais
probablement que lorsqu'on sera dans des
situations à titre personnel où on se
dit je risque d'être contagieux pour
d'autres motifs évidemment que le fait
d'avoir contracté de l'aco vide sera qu'
on aura une plus grande compréhension
des risques encourus par les autres du
simple fait qu'on puisse soi même ne pas
être tout à fait impeccable en terme de
comportement des jeunes mariés parce que
christine rouzioux ce camp quand vous
parlez du modèle japonais sait si la
suite de
de notre action collective face à la
pandémie repose sur cette capacité
cette citoyenneté cette capacité à
mettre le masque dès qu'on est un petit
peu fiévreux etc je ne suis pas sûr que
nos changements d'habitudes avait jusque
là non je suis pas sur mais je pense que
107 en contradiction avec le fait que
c'est vrai que tout le monde que ce soit
fini est terminée et terminé deux fini
ça ça va arriver quand même jeu d'abord
j'en suis pas sûr je pense que septembre
on sait pas ce qui va se passer le virus
circule on a quand même des signaux avec
la circulation du virus dans les
populations animales qui nous
surprennent les soeurs au canada et aux
états unis on a les eaux usées dans new
york où on a des séquences virales dans
les dents des espèces sans doute leur a
tout ça fait que le risque maintenant
vétérinaire et là il est beaucoup mieux
perçue et est donc bon ça veut dire
qu'on a un nombre de recherches whannell
ce plus que jamais sur le haut de 2 des
dossiers mais c'est quand même moi je
perçois comme vous le fait que les gens
mettent une distance on ne se sert plus
la main on a je pense qu'il ya un il ya
des comportements qui sont qui vont pas
revenir de sitôt pour moi c'est une
évidence on n'a pas finalement et c'est
pourquoi j'ai un japonaise un gps vous
ne touchez pas les pôles de quelqu'un
donc sans aller jusqu'à leurs
restrictions qui sont quand même d'ipad
il est difficile pour nous latins on en
voit bien que on va on va bien se laver
les mains les parents ont compris que
les gars sont entérite elles n'ont pas
disparu mais quasi un les rues mais les
enfants les écoles ont appris à laver
les mains les écoles ça ne pose plus de
problèmes tout ça va rester quand même
oui à fond sur tous les enjeux
ces six ans jusqu'à 15 ans ils ont
appris
cet apprentissage
c'était le b à ba en période de virus
respiratoire syncitial et sait on
vraiment on fait très attention à ne pas
contaminer et on sait que le portage des
bactéries et des virus sur les mains et
est vraiment important dans les
contaminations
ça va rester j'avais raison et mais en
même temps on ne peut pas l'interpréter
comme une privation de liberté moi je ne
sais pas d'autres mans c'est sa commune
comme une éducation
et comme un progrès regardez moi quand
j'serai quand j'étais enfant les gens
crachent est partout jeune encore oui en
chine en corée et puis petit à petit à
cause de pasteur à cause de deux coques
etc on a appris un certain nombre de
mesures d'hygiène et on va rajouter à
ces mesures d'hygiène à cause du virus
d'autres mesures qui passeront dans
notre vie quotidienne mais qui ne seront
pas des réceptions de liberté qui seront
une
citoyenne une forme de citoyenneté de
protéger tout le monde et et
d'hygiénisme et d'hygiénisme dans le bon
sens du terme j'ai une petite question
de béotien mais si le masque est plus
obligatoire faïd est de la
responsabilité de chacun mais je pense
qu'il est plus obligatoire dans des
ascenseurs des entreprises dont les
cultes supermarché pourquoi il reste
obligatoire dans les transports parce
que là vraiment c'est confiné et pas
forcément très aéré là le chauffeur de
taxi va pas va pas vous voir arriver
encore tranquille il ya quand même une
certaine angoisse chez un certain sens
écologique on le laisse ou c
annoncé au nom on sait que ce sont des
lieux de contamination et on sait que
ces deux lieux où le virus circule
encore en ce moment voilà c'est ça c'est
sûr maintenant vous avez raison il ya
des supermarchés qui sont pas du tout
aéré yade et vous avez raison mais mais
là les gens savent que dans les lieux
bat r il faut porter le masque il faut
continuer à errer les classes il faut
continuer effectivement ces mesures là
aussi vont rester et je pense que là
encore chacun maintenant a compris où
s'est confinée et où je suis plus
inquiète des boîtes de nuit walla walla
mois les boîtes de nuit je dois avouer
que
je commence à aller au restaurant je
commence à aller un sort en mai le mois
de nuit non ça d'abord celui de mon âge
mais de toutes les façons c'est c'est
quand même des lieux de contamination je
pense j'ai peut-être aussi un autre
aspect si en dehors de la réalité dans
les représentations c'est un des lieux
ont fait aux yeux des français où il ya
le plus grand risque de pouvoir
contracter la comida les transports en
commun donc si jamais en fait il devait
y avoir une psycho supplémentaire du
fait en fait que là aussi en fait les
gestes barrière dont le masque en fait
de mettre retirer peut-être que ray en
fait de nombreuses personnes qui jouent
aujourd'hui prennent les transports en
commun qui ne le prendrai plus et donc
pourra être amené à utiliser un véhicule
individuel et donc avec d'autres
conséquences d'engorgement des villes
etc donc il peut y avoir aussi des
effets qui sont pas uniquement liées à
l'acte à la question objective mais
également représentation subjective et
parfois un côté qui peut être rassurant
même si c'est une privation de liberté
mais pour une partie de la population en
sept ans au moins là j'ai peu de risque
en tout cas pas forcément autant de
risques que ce que je croyais encore une
fois sa part d'un présupposé de départ
extrêmement important le risque élevé
quasiment au même niveau on peut être
aux yeux des français que le fait de
contracter dans une dans une discothèque
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat il